les gens sont persuadés que quand tu
fais la télévision bas tous les soirs au
resto du tapis rouge t'as machin tu as
tout mais en vrai c'était un
salarié quoi qu'est ce que tu vas au
resto et en plus tu payes pas toi
et tu peux te faire moi je moi nrj12
j'ai été viré le maine le matin le mal
je n'en savais pas le matin pour le soir
j'étais viré après dix ans comme un mec
chez renault ou chez france télécom du
des salariés tâter juste atteint mettait
dans la lumière du soir ils vous ont dit
quoi que la balle était à l'époque
c'était vincent broussard le patron et
ils m'ont dit quoi franchement le matin
il m'a dit est ce que tu veux venir dans
le bureau mais dont j'étais persuadé que
c'était pour renouveler le contrat est
pour eux
et en fait je sais comment c'est passé
j'arrive dans le bureau et puis une du
baath un petit peu avant qu'on se parle
de la rentrée le juge attend un petit
peu et puis je bois je lui fais tu peux
pas dire s'il te plaît et l'art est une
personne la drh et du juridique chez ses
parents
et puis en fait ils étaient trois et
puis ils m'ont dit voilà on va arrêter
mais je voulais arrêter quoi et bientôt
au toit non mais oui mais oui c'est à
dire on arrête toi voilà et donc
pourquoi ben alors en fait ce qui
m'avait dit c'est qu'à l'époque il
voulait il voulait changer l'image de la
chaîne et ses skis médicaments et que
j'étais l'étendard de quelque chose
qu'ils ne voulaient plus représenté
hélas tu as dit peut-être un coup sur la
tête bah bah oury sortent du bureau tu
dois être au bout de table ben je la
vérité alors je sors du bureau je
j'appelle mon meilleur ami qu'était
fogel et judy je suis viré et voilà je
sais pas insisté salariés dont j'ai pu
rien et je me suis dit qu'est ce que je
vais faire et comme j'ai pas de système
pas propriétaire ni rien je me suis dis
bah il m'a dit premier truc que tu fais
vente à bagnols tu vas vivre quelques
mois avec et je vous jure que c'est vrai
une semaine après j'étais à boulogne le
téléphone sonne numéro inconnu je
réponds j'entends
bbc il décider si j'étais vous qui
m'appelait dans la rue et qui me dit est
ce que tu veux venir faire des
chroniques et des machins exactement à
une semaine près comme comme ça que ça
s'est passé ça que j'ai suivi un petit
peu la cuvée vous étiez
chalmé s'est passé voilà une semaine
comme ça ouais ouais c'est s'il faut
quand il faut il faut garder en tête ça
donne quand vous êtes parti de france
télé aussi cette verdure non mais en
fait c'est enfin c'était c'était
particulier parce que moi je suis c'est
moi qui suis partie je partis de tf1 et
je suis parti de france télévision parce
que moi j'ai besoin d'eux d'être désiré
c'est à dire j'ai besoin que ça marche
dans les deux sens qu'on me dise on
envie de toi on a besoin de toi etc et
quand on sent que ça ça fonctionne pas
de toute façon on va délivrer quelque
chose qui va pas être blanc les
téléspectateurs vont le sentir mais
effectivement il ya une sorte de petite
mort c'est à dire qu'à un moment le
téléphone sonne plus vraiment alors on
voit c'est là où on voit la garde
rapprochée bien sûr mais et c'est là où
moi je dis tout le temps il faut penser
que la télé c'est un métier mais il faut
avoir pleins d'autres métiers annexes
faire de la radio écrire des livres etc
pour pas tout d'un coup se retrouvèrent
dans sa longue et jamais lâché mais pour
ce jeu pour qu' il n'est pas ce truc
d'abyssales de touba berger le vide j'ai
plus rien bien sûr il donc voilà il ya
besoin d'être maintenant sont souvenus
matters producteurs parce que sinon ben
ça peut directeur des programmes kemp
nagl et ben t'es tu perds ta put rien on
est des chiens dangereux sont deux
générations
non mais moi je peux me faire virer du
jour au lendemain et si oui les mains
pour l'ego maintenant on est tranquille
moi